yeah that was pretty good I wish I was
some other people that could just force
it but I can't so I mean you have to
swallow air and then like that swallower
some people like that when they he they
just they Chow their food there you go
oh my god shall their food and a bunch
of air and then they just Wow okay that
works let's go one two three four you
made up my childhood
[Music]
I
more than a pretty face you must be
quiet
Sonia said ways to you will never be
[Music]
your may rain it stays reflected in
those
seven your story and and watch it
janitrol your dedication
incise vulnerable t but hot right swag
meters and my
[Music]
thank you for sharing your hub with me
never know your impacts read through
more than one yeah
[Music]
princess oh you were one of
[Music]
okay that's pretty good yeah I got one
good say okay good
I still feel like I need to back that is
any no I think I got that I got the
picking pattern I lost I'm gonna get
[Music]
I messed up before I went into the
ending I miss oh I wonder what that was
okay
yeah okay oh you can
[Music]
No